let's see if we can find the product of
X minus 4 and I'll put that in
parentheses the product of that and X
plus 7 and like always I encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can
figure it out on your own well there are
a bunch of different ways to tackle
multiplying two binomials like this but
the way that I like to tackle it
especially if we're just learning how to
do this is to just realize that we can
apply the distributive property that we
all know and love and how do you do that
well you could just think of this X
minus 4 we can distribute the entire
binomial we can multiply the X minus 4
times the X and we can multiply it times
the 7 so let me rewrite this so we can
write rewrite this as if we distribute
it it would be X minus 4 times this x
times that blue X and then plus we're
also distributing the X minus 4 we have
to distribute on all every one of these
terms so it's also so plus X minus 4 X
minus 4 times this is 7 times the 7 now
what is this going to be on the left
hand side well the x times the X is
going to be x squared and then the x
times this is minus 4 or x times the
negative 4 is negative 4x and then over
here I distribute the 7 7 times X is 7x
so plus 7x and then 7 times negative 4
is negative 28 and now we can simplify
this a little bit we see that we have
two first-degree two terms two terms
where I have a certain number of X's and
so we can combine these so I have x
squared if I take these two middle terms
if I take negative 4 X and then add 7
X's that's going to give me positive 3x
negative 4 plus 7 is positive 3 so
positive 3x and of course we have the we
have the minus 28 and we're done we just
multiplied these two binomials just
using the distributive property to
ice first we distributed the entire X -4
on to the X plus 7 so you have X minus 4
times X plus X minus 4 times the 7 and
then we distributed the X onto the X
minus 4 to get what we see in yellow
here and we distribute to the 7 on to
the X minus 4 it is to get what we got
in green here and then we just simplify
it a bit